Vanessa Hudgins stepping out and showing
off her new bling dreams do come true
and dreams come in all shapes and ring
sizes a week after fans learned she and
boyfriend Cole Tucker plan to tie the
knot Vanessa confirms the news on
Instagram I'm so so grateful not only
did the actress post about the
announcement but she was snapped on a
night out in Los Angeles with family
rocking her new bling cozy Vibes only
Vanessa's decked out in comfy wear
matching sweater and sweats paired of
course with some fluffy slippers I think
that it's also so important to stay
grateful for everything that you have in
life
um and I've been making that a priority
the couple got engaged at the end of
2022 following two years of dating it's
just easy uh we're like the same person
very much the same person but with
different interests so it's cool and
their meeting story well it's a good one
when my girlfriend was on this Zoom
meditation group and everyone's sending
like Gifts of themselves so like I sent
a gif of myself and then there's like a
gif in the group chat of like a baseball
player and he's sliding onto a base and
I thought it was a joke so I just
responded hot
and then they get on the zoom and I'm
like
yeah who is that dude you gotta love it
if I want something or someone I'm going
after them like I I fully just slid into
his DMS and the baseball player
certainly appreciates a good slide it
looks like Vanessa's scouted a good one
whether it's on the red carpet or
AstroTurf fans are loving how these two
show their support yeah it's great I
mean it's really cute because I I during
his season I've I've come to a lot of
games way more than I have in my entire
life condensed into a year
um and and it's so fun like I love going
and supporting and cheering him on but
for the premiere days he's like it's
game day babe he's like it's so nice I
get to come to your game and I'm like
it's
yes
same thing
um but it's great he's amazing
[Music]